we've got beautiful skies out there
everybody whether you're playing
baseball this weekend or you're going to
one of the festivals or or doing one of
those wonderful walks on saturday
excuse me it looks like the weather's
going to cooperate now we're going to
get a little wind there's something else
going on though saturday night if you
want to watch the skies and i know i
have a lot of folks that love watching
the skies and knowing what's going on
it's
international observe the moon night
that's tomorrow the moon won't be full
the full moon is actually the 20th
next week a moon rise by the way is 4 33
and it sets at 2 46 a.m so you do have
to get out there it's nice to see it
when it's dark but it's the one night
across the northern uh
north tier of the uh of the globe excuse
me when it's you can really see the good
detail
it's usually after the first quarter of
the moon and not quite full you can
really see the good details so i'll put
more details of that on my facebook page
lots of 50s around the valley this
morning not those chilly 40s low 40s out
at red rock and 30s up at kyle canyon do
have some 40s at indian springs and
prompt you're right there close to 40 in
the 40s 50 right now 52 in mesquite all
right laughlin has already had winds
over 30 miles an hour we're going to get
the strongest winds along the river
today a few snow showers left in the
intermountain west and big thunderstorms
expected along that strike zone if you
will with the cool air clashing with
really warm moist air in the eastern
third of the u.s so the ohio and
tennessee valleys i'm afraid we'll have
severe weather today we're going to stay
dry but we will stay breezy and there
are santa ana winds with fire weather
warnings across southern california
today so unfortunately that's really
upping the fire weather dangers there 73
degrees we should be in the low 80s so
staying nicely below normal for a while
until we get to the weekend so tomorrow
beautiful upper 70s saturday afternoon
some clouds around but not too cloudy on
sunday 80 and that's another cold front
moving through so we take a little slide
on monday and tuesday with temperatures
back to low 80s warm again later next
week